citizens of the reject Nation it is time for
the Mitchells versus the machines are you
the Mitchells are you the machine I will be the
machines Roxy on the Mitchell that's right so you
got to take me down thank you so much John John
you had a fun fact about this obviously because
it's one of the best films of 2021 but also it's
from one of the directors of the new Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles Mutant Mayhem it has a 97
on the Tomato Meter so we are required to love
it yeah well we're at least required to like it as
you guys are required to like this video yeah it's
not like a requirement as much as an ass it's a
strong suggestion yeah we also suggest that you
subscribe while you're there do your thing and
thank you so much we really appreciate prepper
for editing this reaction and also if you want
more of us if you want to see the whole the full
length reaction and sync up with us in order to
do that what do you got to do you got to come
over patreon.com the real rejects grab your own
copy and join us I like the way you do that this
is my muppet hands oh why isn't Muppet hands I
don't know because they're Wiggly and wavy do it
with machine hands instead because we're about to
watch the Mitchells versus the Russians here we go
we all want to be the perfect family every
family has its challenges from picture day
to picky eaters okay for my family our
greatest challenge probably the machine
apocalypse I was gonna say it was like wake up
it looked like the absolute perfect family wait
they're coming sensible the way he said
wait is like when you go to cross the street
or is it
the Mitchells they must be there we are
warriors most action heroes have a lot
of strengths Dad look out lady use a
weapon my family only has weaknesses
okay you're gonna learn to
use them to your advantage
my dad kind of reminds me of that
YouTube screaming Gibbon monkey foreign
legitimately thought it froze oh
someone had fun editing this it was
strapped in for Success sure and we have no
idea what we're doing I took
the words right out of my mouth
I love all the little uh hand-drawn
animated flourishes this is a
a few days earlier robot apoc
alypse is really hit all in one go
oh no I fly with us Ed they all blinked
at the same time that was so funny
[Applause]
I never fit in it's okay I liked your burger
movie my little brother Aaron gets me but he's
got his own weird interests hi would you
like to talk to me about dinosaurs no okay
thank you oh oh my dude one of them's
gonna be a bite says that to everyone
I think this main girl is Abby Jacobson
A for effort Buster Brown oh my dad is
an unusual man Broad City Girl Is
That Jackalope he loves nature and
can fix anything to survive in the outdoors
you'll need to know how to trap wild games
I poured everything I had into
getting into Film School in la oh
same girl it's me I'm literally
inspired by this right now I'm
I'd love to accept [Music] oh my God please accept
her I'm sitting here like what's my excuse for not
making a bunch of DIY short films now and other
accepted students totally get me by the way
I need those earrings the most positive
film students do you really think I'll
be okay without you I know you
will reactor Bash oh Raptor Bash
personal assistant
that's horrifying I hate that now I'm
about to drop our biggest invention yet
your cell phone is about to take its first
steps oh my we're gonna be all the way in
California and you know we're not gonna be able
to help you you know if things don't pan out
okay you know what I'm just gonna oh look I'll
watch that it's too late I want to watch it oh
no no no let go yes is exactly why I'm excited to
leave tomorrow ouch at least it wasn't before she
submitted her application it's true probably
a student discount on a replacement look
we always arguing oh oh well what about that one
he's a real soccer [Music] big again that's
a problem I don't think we can fix yep now
October 3rd that's the Mean Girls
down dude hey my whole my Yahoo
downloads early yeah
[Music]
all right thank you good setup oh
put in the giveaway that's what that's what
he pulled it out of that's sad we are going
to drive you to school on a cross-country
road trip as a family Aaron you too bye
I thought it could be cool to hang out one last
time oh a mixer dad a mixer a mixer family alone
for hours in a car you and me oh my God on the
one hand it's nice to have a dad who's willing to
drive you to school yeah on the other hand no this
family has communication issues yeah this place
has literally zero stars on Yelp it says do not
eat here ever what are we gonna let a nap tell us
get those Mr Beast Burgers you pay for it I signed
this up for a seven hour mule tour dad doesn't
that sound Steep and dangerous Katie what could
go wrong get to the bridge if you want to live
behold the magic hey Dad can you check
the trunk yeah sure oh nasty dang it
it's excitable
I do like meta modern comedy for the amount
of riffs on like Tech bro Society we get yeah
my private emails wait they're private emails
that's a dangerous overreach of corporate power
whoa ethical okay you know I created you when
I was a young man whatever happens out there
I will never forget you pal oh so scary dude
it's gonna be like a twisted version of her
it's gonna be hers Terminator and after all
those years she complete oh jeez dude [Music]
this is the newest member
oh yeah pal Max pal Max Plus pal Max Ultra
removing meaningless garbage cheese are they gonna
turn evil well I've insured their safety with
the code in case anything go goes
wrong oh that's reassuring yeah [Music]
no hey we're here to help please
remain calm while we capture you
oh they're like Cybermen no Mark we have
been given new orders by who great leader
the Bots kind of sound like uh the guy
who does the ghost face voice and scream
cool image wowie beautiful
that's you remember
oh guys maybe I'm a little too old oh
no wait we can still sing it uh if you
want okay never mind we don't have to do this
thing along if you don't want to brutal foreign
togetherness trip we've been having so much fun
look here's Us in St Louis this is us at the
beach and This Is Us gas outside it's all a lie
social media lie I'm happy you're never from home
sorry super into dinosaurs check
out this pencil topper yeah
oh yeah Romance say something no I
hate that no [Music] why do you do that why do you
do that it's bro code what is that meteor shower
it and leave three likes
world oh
wow what happened to you this morning
I know I'm gonna ask the flashback wow
oh wow what are these robots greetings of you
doesn't seem good that they're counting us
never they're like the
iRobot robots it's like sunny
and hey I like fun oh no you do not like fun
everyone says that about man oh my wow I wish
I could Swan to join him whoa what would a
functional family do right now we've trained
for this Jim you go high all go low ready I
love you all so much butterfly formation yeah
this is dragon say the South face
cheese
triceratopos wow be a hero take some notes kids
no charge it robot to fly into
Sky well okay what's next then
yes
Munchies
[Music] oh boy honestly
unfortunately you let Mochi go
wow wow oh look at that little
bite like battle droids too
yes you knew it I gave you all boundless
knowledge endless tools for creativity and
allowed you to magically talk face to face
with your loved ones anywhere on Earth it's
Olivia common 100 give me some nachos no I
don't have any time to wash my hands jeez
Cal Labs family why would you think I don't still
god dude Mark you threw me away you even do
it to your real families did you know 90 of
calls from mums get ignored oh it's not me you're
one of the good ones rocks well my mom's dead so
we're still gonna count that give me a single
single your species worth saving because humans
have The Power of Love do you mark oh wow
I've never seen somebody deserve that more
than him yeah a little bit I'm team Olivia Coleman
watch what happens when I'm live with Andy Cohen
are you connected to ethernet
foreign
this came out during the pandemic
right yeah I think so whoa
robot overlord's got style I gotta say
I'm a big neon girl do you think that
Olivia Coleman's enemy or Mark is the enemy
who's the antagonist here maybe she'll turn
out to just be misunderstood and
secretly wants to just be loved
it's gonna be okay is it first thing is hand
over your devices I'll give them right back
I'm just gonna turn them off permanently
smash them oh Jeeps next did everyone bring
your personalized number three Robertson
Ed non-slip screwdriver Robertson head my
anniversary present or my sweet 16 gift or
with the tooth fairy left under my pillow
disguise ourselves as the enemy oh sweet
he's gonna say no make a nickel set of
robot fingers Mad Max now world saving
apocalyptic Road Warriors I'm with it
it's not open for discussion let's
keep barricading Aaron you get this
listen to your daughter dude she's very smart you
raised her well she's probably
seen like every sci-fi movie
you can still wear these guys carcasses what's
happening with those Twitchy
twitch they're gonna come back
how did this human about the
kill oh hi take cover go go go go
oh so many screws look for the kill switch
hey Eric my name is also Eric oh I mean Deborah
bought five thousand idiot Deborah
bought five thousand you guys said
we have the kill code stored in
our memory but to enacted you
would have to embark on a perilous Journey yeah
in Silicon Valley surrounded by a robot army
and entered into a great and powerful leader to
destroy her you could also make also I don't code
remotely at any pal Labs retail store there's one
at the mall of the globe and nearby shopping oh
that's Fred Armisen okay Rick Mitchell taught us
to be bold never played safe the world needs you
I need you Yep this is amazing let's feel this
energy your plans working Dad Dad Katie's plan
honey I respect your ideas and value your opinions
you're hey you're drawing actually worked I art
could be useful you see the clutch is the distance
oh no you have to go up the mountains
oh [Music]
them Hazard boys every single person
on the planet actually I'm actually
we're Fierce Brave oh no powerful
loneliest child insert the Mitchells
garbage I need more buddy they
appear to be headed to some place
called Mall of the Colorado when
they get there we'll be ready yes
it's good morale among the robots is that a dog
or a dog pig dog Pig loaf of bread system error
oh come on guys it's a dog it's a
combination of a pug and Grumpy Cat
See's Candies and skin where is this movie
going we're about halfway through like we
just got to the mall yeah seems like this
ought to be the end but there's so much
more to go I order you to upload
the kill code and save the world
upload the kill count what's your best robot
voice my best robot voice sounds like this
okay I appreciate your approval
Roxanne really good foreign
[Music]
she closed it it's not gonna
upload while you close it
but will it save your progress I don't know
that's always the question yeah game time oh
I like that half the stores are real and
half the stores are like gags Cutting Edge
holistic skills whoa It's like this
would be fun if it wasn't so scary yeah
what was that what was that
oh no no Furbies Furbies
it's bad it's back [Music] five nights at Furbies
oh no no [Laughter]
Furby Kaiju
this is amazing
let the dark Harvest I wonder if the younger gen
has any idea that Furbies are real watching this
they do now that'll be the fun in
like 20 years people Googling half
the things are just made up half
the things we're like oh it's a
real product whoa thank you human are
you now my mother yes are you my mother
mom even after you closed it
I'm trying to place his voice this whole time
he's too happy about all this did he cause this
I mean he must have manifested it at least
come on he needs more weight
jump up there fam yeah [Music]
robots come on robots [Music]
[Music]
oh no no she's not gonna be able to upload it
uh
right we don't have a normal
dog or a normal car oh
bizarre this group of weirdos
is the best hope Humanity's got
this is really effing cute yeah I'm really
enjoying this there's like footage of a slow
motion fire behind us it's like Heroes Haiti
that would be of time and absolutely unnecessary
[Laughter]
kind of get battle with that on our
Humanity in there this is Kill Bill
reference I'm super into this right
now yeah same oh I'm a freaky pal
there's a sign on the road for garlic I
I oh no death Troopers yes my
queen oh my god wow [Music]
have they not been seeing this the whole
time or did it like change direction or
something oh I guess yeah okay
there we go they're seeing the
master plan for the first time V
for Vendetta it is fuzzy okay oh
except he told her he hates her that means he
loves her just not speak we can't teach little
boys anymore that they can be mean to little
girls and little girls are supposed to know
they like them no we gotta start them young we
gotta build that toxicity at the root Mitchell
Mitchell
yeah this movie's so quirky I know you
know who couldn't make this AI shots
fired careful all the machines are listening
right now I'm on the lookout for these Goobers
probably nearby these Goofy Goobers look
for anyone who can't keep it together
it only takes one single imperfection
and they'll reveal themselves
keep it cool even like the writing on her
hand it's just all so smart no like so many
great details yeah I think this is fooling
anyone they're being nice to each other
they're pretending oh no they're gonna
show her telling the kid the brother
whoa [Music]
oh no [Music] the way they did that
I thought it was like almost like a
dream sequence like he didn't
really drop it but then he did
we will help you no no no no no
you don't download new orders
no you don't have to listen to
her we're sorry mother Jesus
he knew this was coming Pete
it's all up to you siblings I
love all the Sci-Fi visuals too
oh buddy sacrifice one last something to
remember the place by what cool pillars
come on oh the Moose comes from there yeah he
built all that go get your daddy back considering
these weird girls videos always cheer
me up bye Otter's that weird girl
she's hilarious these movies are like
amazing hey but now that I'm leaving
film has so much subtext pretty on the
nose it's art it's real life dog Shield
s
[Laughter]
oh my ramp it ramp it thank her dad what's it
called the special across the Stream [Music]
driving the stick [Music]
to me controls are in here but to open
it you need a number three Robertson
head non-slip screwdriver what kind of
maniac has one of those in his pockets
I've waited so long for this day
he keeps anticipating our Maneuvers how is
this possible no I don't know you tell me yes
that was the best
there you go hey
hold up [Music] hit by a train
it's not even know how to spell YouTube w
ow no no no
later okay yeah fine that's fine oh five
minutes no oh English what have I done
yet yes
we regulate tapioca he is
oh geez I've had nightmares
like this yeah I feel uh
Karen no no
he's got a screwdriver he's gonna figure
it out too he's got to they all got one
more Kill Bill
the iron side theme
yeah
let's go
what a legend boss hey
hey whoa here we go video uh
uh see see come on hit C [Music]
akes
[Music]
hey
let's see faced in using a computer
you changed your programming is that
possible oh yes oh they recognize gross
it might be one of the only things that are
oh dear you will drop each
other the first chance you get
yes
change your programming
muscle spread
stuff I've read [Music]
oh you too
programming we decide to sunshowers that's so
great yeah that is both like exciting and sinister
why are those guys heads exploding we can tell
the difference between dog and pig and bread dad
this one's for you play our song yes yes [Music]
I have chills all over my entire body right now
yes oh [Music]
yes I want to be the fluff in this family
absolutely I'll be the banana slices
yes Queen
whoa
I'm not just a human [Music]
saving you from this [__] you
[Music] oh look straight [Music]
you know what this reminds me of
whoa
what happens to all the pods they're
gonna have to get everybody a Robertson
head screwdriver or whatever thanks
Linda you guys were incredible you're
so brave and so authentic you've inspired
me to follow you on Instagram oh my gosh
get that follow I I just want to say I think
you're really neat and I wonder if you come
over to my house and talk about dinosaur s sure
I'll talk about dinosaurs I'm just kidding [Music]
[Music]
she's joshing with him
get a picture here or what we're
making memories here baby no we
want them in the picture they're
part of the family oh this is so
good no Phone Zone in the car you'd
be the most popular girl in school
you saved the entire world
I got nothing to worry about
you even figured out
[Laughter] don't let the world making armor while
I'm gone okay I never will oh every week Dr Bash
good luck finding your people Dad look
at my people you guys are my people
family do you remember how Moose says I love you
[Music]
he
ah Hey where's Aaron let me just
showed you oh he's on date Abby
want to show your sister who you're talking to why
oh my some honor or something
we have to go to Washington DC
do you guys want to fly or
is there a sequel oh yeah
oh
oh one big road trip and family
what oh
I don't get it like the family the
Mitchells but what do they actually do
be a family and Inspire
this heartwarming tale cute
it's lovely though I like that they Grace the
credits as a little baby oh perfect I thought it
was dancing bro damn Abby Jacobson gotcha sure
my Rudolph do you think it was the mom though
her voice Eric Andre Eric Andre I thought it was
like a low-key Good Michael Key but there you go
okay John Legend and Chrissy Teigen okay not bad
because it must have been the neighbors right yeah
at least I got one yep yeah I got one Roxanne
yeah you you killed it you crushed that's right
oh and a mark mothers boss score and all not bad
dude what'd you think of the movie man that was
really really good that was a delight I you know
sometimes I get nervous because I told you going
into this 97 on the Tomato Meter is like and I
didn't know one thing that this movie was about
but it's just like what are the chances it's gonna
be that good there's one thing I heard about this
movie beforehand everyone obviously said it was
great but everyone's like it's really overwhelming
it's like it's really visually like crazy and
overwhelming um I didn't and I used to be very
overwhelming no I thought it was just right now
weird but great no it's like it it matches the
themes perfectly and uh I thought that yeah like
it it was certainly kinetic it certainly had like
a very Lively uh uh you know oh hey one of the uh
main guys was like the voice Baron it's cool uh
yeah no it's like it's definitely got like a lot
of visual energy and stuff like that and a lot of
like little details and like blink and you'll miss
it uh gags and stuff like that but I thought this
had like such wonderful energy and I loved the
way that you're seeing the movie partly through
you know Katie's perspective you're seeing through
her imagination of how this would look like part
of me was like oh I bet they're gonna end on like
the cut together version of their movie Adventure
from her camcorder or whatever yeah me too but
really like the whole movie is kind of that anyway
it's like you know you're constantly cutting
away to these like smash title cards or you've
got these little animations popping up just to
accentuate certain moments and and yeah like it's
very of the here and now but in a way that I think
doesn't sacrifice any amount of just like quality
storytelling and character and and you know
good messaging all that stuff I'm a sucker for
everything that this movie tried to do so like and
I'm sure a lot of people are but father-daughter
relationships I really dig sure like a mother's
love overtaking robots I really dig sibling
relationships brother sister stuff I really dig so
it's like and fighting and you know raging Against
the Machine I really do absolutely um so for all
those reasons it's like yeah obviously this worked
for me but then on top of all that it it takes
massive swings because it is so weird it is so
quirky and people might have just been like this
is too much for me but it for some reason all the
pieces just kind of like majorly worked for me it
was like the more they threw it to me the more I
fell in love with it and with the characters like
from The Shining socks to her chipped nail polish
to the writing on her hand and every little detail
there to the earrings of her mom with the hearts
and like getting to know each of these characters
who were so fully fleshed out you you see them
you know them you get them like you see all the
relationships and and none of them are just like
horrible people they just they're not seeing eye
to eye very common in families especially during
transitional times as somebody's going to college
I'm just like about it I'm just that's how I'm
like oh gushy about it well and I thought that
the the theme of yeah like family is difficult
and it's all choices that you make and it's all
moments that you do these things out of love for
people despite you know maybe the fact that you
might not be feeling the exact same way at the
exact same moment all those little things and
I thought that they managed to pit that really
nicely against the argument of like you know
Humanity being dominated by robots and like what's
the point what's the quality of human beings like
what's the point of of you know allowing all this
chaos that you guys create all this mess that you
guys create and like you know it's not the newest
concept but I thought it managed to spin it really
really conscientiously without yeah sacrificing
the fun or the impact you know and definitely and
yeah like I I loved just the way that they drew
the dysfunction of the family and the ways that
they've grown apart and the aspects of especially
between parents and kids like the sacrifices that
you don't realize are being made and you know the
growths that are happening um and the ways in
which we we try really hard and sometimes make
things worse even from our best intentions you
know and our most sort of loving inclinations and
stuff like that I liked also so sweet yeah yeah
I like the the Side Story lines the B storyline
C story lines too like with the neighbors always
comparing yourself to people and at the end of
the day like your superpower is being you and and
excelling in your family and not trying to be this
Yoga Retreat family which if you are that you are
that but if you're not that just working on what
you are or like even the Side Story with the son
not knowing who he was going to be friends with
um and the finding Abby in that you know um or
even the little bit of time that we spent with
the college friends right like and and the lesson
to people just I remember feeling in high school
like what's gonna happen am I not gonna find
my people I feel like an outcast I feel like
a weirdo sometimes um and then when you do grow
up your friends don't have to be the people that
just live close to you your friends are the people
that have the same interests as you right and like
that is out there for everybody that if you can go
and find that you don't yeah just I just it felt
this is such a weird comment after this movie it
felt very the theme so very realistic sure well
no that's I think that's the grounded beautiful
part of it yeah is that it is so wild and mad cap
and imaginative but like I think that's a really
kind of interesting Nuance to touch upon is that
is that you can have one without having to get
rid of the other it's like you know you can you
can go find your people you can get out on your
own you can you know explore and find the people
who share your interests but it doesn't mean
that you have to just leave your family because
people are always your people and then you have
other people you can find for different reasons
yeah 100 it's like your people becomes this tribe
over time that that you connect with over so many
different things and people that you've spent
so much time with like your family can often
feel yeah like you know ah you know I've outgrown
this or or you know we've we've done that I need
something new but you know there's still that
thing that you come back to and that Foundation
I mean you know certainly there are dysfunctional
families but uh at least here like I thought the
way they drew that just the the friction between
that her wanting to get out on her own and really
Express herself and her dad especially not really
understanding her expression um and yet still kind
of finding all the things that they have in common
you know again didn't it didn't feel cheesy or or
you know trite in that way and I love that that
bit of like she's been recording her movies on
these old DB tapes that have all their family you
know home videos on them and stuff I was worried
she recorded over them though I hope she didn't
record over some of them yeah hopefully those are
the ones that didn't matter as much what did you
think about the animation in this it was It was
kind of simple but like also intense well yeah I
I love what I mean you know I feel like Phil Lord
and Chris Miller get so much of the credit for so
many of these movies just like kind of in totality
um but I feel like between like spider-verse
movies and and this and various projects of
theirs it is clear that they're able to they seem
to like a certain kinetic kind of Animation but
that's also like very rich with like colliding
approaches and styles and things like that like
this in a way kind of reminded me of something
like a spider verse or even what mutant Mayhem
looks like in terms of the animation where it's
like you know it feels clearly computer animated
but there's something that feels maybe just
a little bit more sort of handcrafted about
it and like in this in particular I loved all
the cartoon flourishes of you know having all
these different like things pop up on screen
they're like 2D animation or meme Graphics or
things like that like this still managed to
feel like sort of multimedia yeah definitely
every time even like the live action stuff that
we saw at the beginning and then we smash it
down or whatever that was really cool I also
love the music choices the way that it sounded
um and just I know that it's a couple years old
at this point but it felt so it felt like it came
out today and it's only going to appreciate in
allegorical value 100 like the live your life
thing I mean it was really cute it is it's hard
the when the father to nail the father-daughter
thing is so difficult in movies because it's like
you guys are they're the furthest away from each
other and the family right like the most different
probably but to find that connection between them
and to go back in those old videos and to have
the live your life kind of through line of it
it's just really really precious yeah and I
thought that was even well chosen because in
the here and now that song is a little bit past
its moment it's past that moment of like Peak
relevancy and so you can kind of get on her uh
you can get on board with how she's feeling like
I'm kind of embarrassed like this is kind of hard
now it's kind of cringe now you're never too old
for Rihanna yeah but then you know tapping into
again the fun and the abandon and little things
like that like I like the the other family like
didn't turn out to be like oh secretly terrible
or like oh no we're secretly like completely
horrible and depressed inside and we just put
this image like it didn't seem like it needed
to like slight any characters or look down on
characters definitely imagine like if if behind
the robots have been the family next door would
have been like man like come on and that too I
really like liked the array of and I'm sure that
there are more you can pick out as you if you
go through and pause and scrub and stuff but I
like the movie references in and of themselves
because certainly like robot apocalypse isn't
the newest idea but like this was reminding
me of kind of it it almost reminded me of like
her meets like Terminator Genesis meets like a
family Road Trip movie or something like that
which I thought was really fun and I mean yeah
like the further we get into the future in Ai
and interconnected smart devices you know like
this will be well taught in territory but uh
but yeah I don't know I just thought they made uh
it didn't seem like they left any gags you know I
have a question for you yeah what's that why is it
worth keeping humans alive because we got family
all of a sudden you're Vin Diesel yeah man this
is the official spokes model of family cool she's
like don't say because people lead with love and
whatever and I was like well that is kind of why
I mean like every every like massive alien Wipeout
movie is always like what is your guy's deal and
we're always like we're messy but we love so look
under Mochi it's Doug the Pug yeah man what doug
the Pug made the sounds apparently dug the Pug
tug the Pug I'd like to meet you yeah maybe we
can get dug the Pug on for an exclusive interview
you would say I'm not a pig I'm not a pig nor am I
red and I do not appreciate being regarded as such
I actually don't feel like I could have liked that
movie more I yeah like I'm I'm so just delighted
I don't really have much of any sort of wild
complaints again I feel like yeah like some of the
themes are certainly trodden by other pieces of
media but this was just it just felt just as long
as it needed to be the humor was tight and snappy
the characters were distinct the voice acting was
quality and it was like they had you know a lot
of celebrity voices but in capacities where you
kind of had to wonder a little bit like you know
oh this isn't exactly what I would expect from
this particular actor or this particular actor
um yeah yeah it was just like it had all
the Sci-Fi fun and bounce but it also had
the touching and and as like you know the film
student of of old I didn't spoke to that part
too I was like these are the most positive
supportive film students ever no one's yeah
no one's shaming anybody for their taste
yeah well that's the new Jen's coming up
they're way uh yeah they're kind about things
uh any other movie thoughts Gotta Kill Bill
references uh a lot of references what was
the one movie they called out straight up
all right or you guys can refresh our memories
for us that's what that is interesting they had
half and half on the product placement it's like
half the stores and and restaurants and things
are like recognizable Brands and then half of
them are are gags I like that yeah yeah I mean
which is nice because I think then you're not
only looking at the background the whole time
because I think like in things that are like
really heavy on like just tons and tons and
tons of like blink and you'll miss it gags
sometimes that'll bring you to watching the
background rather than the I love the Furby
thing that was great yeah the kirbys man it
could have been beanie babies but it was not
it was more specific it was logical yeah the
tech in exactly that's why they had those pal
chips in them and you guys are our Pals you
are our Pals you see what I did because the
pal chip beautiful Segway right there there
are Pals and uh you know who's our biggest
pal our Patron pal who are we shouting at
um
the Mitchells versus the machine shout
out Martinez Ricardo Martinez we got there
Martinez versus the machines oh you gotta do
Martinez versus The Machinist yeah oh there you
go or the uh yeah the the last makina I don't
know what the Spanish is I'm sorry I feel like
there was that moment in the movie where they
had you know the presentation by the robots
um well I also thought were very funny we didn't
really talk about the robots in the review I'm
sorry the robots across the board that's true
they were great with the stuff on their face too
um but in the YouTube he went to Spanish
specifically yeah so Martinez versus the machines
we could get a whole Spanish language remake of
this movie just like they did with Dracula back
in the 1930s or whatever because there's Dracula
but then there's also Spanish Dracula where they
shot on the same sets Justice is that true Knight
yes and apparently it's like the same sets they
shot it at night when the regular Dracula Bella
Lugosi crew left and I had some people say that
it's like slightly better than Dracula Dracula
you never checked it out so I haven't yet because
I'm saving it for when me and Ricardo have a
movie night oh that's right Martinez versus the
move the well maybe he can Cinema captain your
ship Ricardo picardo boom there was a Star Trek
reference somewhere in this movie as well remember
you said Star Trek and I was like yeah what was it
it's like a billboard for Trek something oh all
right well let's track our way to saying thank
you Ricardo Martinez and thank you to everybody
for watching this we appreciate you guys let us
know who won Mitchell or the machine I think
I kicked your butt you you said you were in
the machine you kicked my Butts oh that was
the point of the whole video uh don't forget
like subscribe all that stuff and we'll see you
here next time Ron joxie out to be moist [Music]